[Musique]
tout comme il est entré dans une salle
oms il ya la télévision le sport serait
vite au musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines
les équipes ont travaillé sur l'histoire
de l'agglomération et de sa relation
avec le sport c'est une exposition du
cou qui retrace l'histoire du sport sur
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines et dans la vie de ses habitants
c'est pour cela qu'elle s'appelle dans
la vie comme à la ville elle se divise
en trois parties une partie qui
s'appelle la ville en sport qui retrace
du coup le développement du sport sur le
territoire des premiers stades qui était
deschamps prêté par la sncf au grand
stade qu'on peut connaître maintenant
ensuite on arrive dans une deuxième
partie qui s'appelle spectaculaire mon
sport qui retrace du coup l'histoire de
deux équipements phares du territoire
qui sont le golf national elle vélodrome
nationale qui nous ont permis d'avoir de
nombreux prêts afin d'exposer du coup un
vélo et différents équipements utilisés
par les sportifs établir son régime
alimentaire découvrir le mode sportswear
au fil des années et révéler son profil
sportif
la troisième partie le sport au
quotidien et plus interactive et en fait
seul au sommet ça nous proposant fois
mais scénographe nicolas franches aux et
stéphane guillon il souhaitait une
installation moderne des logiciels
d'informatique ont été spécialement
développés comme la skysports c'est une
carte en fait qu'ils présentent on va
dire comme un élément complémentaire à
l'exposition où on peut retrouver les
différents équipements du territoire
l'exposition sport à la vie comme à la
ville est ouverte au public jusqu'au 9
mars 2019